both are playing on very very low times  so  check is completely winning now yeah you  can take on H4 but it doesn't really  matter because it's about who will be  faster and so far Vincent is being very  fast but the Among Us will obviously not  hesitate to  uh to flag here  oh okay not needed because for instance  somehow removed all of his Rooks away  and that was a nice day and lost on time  yeah  so yeah Winston managed to actually lose  this position on the board somehow  because Rook G6 he could have if he saw  that wg6 was played he could have taken  96 and taken on A5 and it is guaranteed  a draw but instead he pre-moved all of  these moves and uh yeah  foreign  not great  not great dubov actually won that game  against Olympic shot  Gwen Jones was a draw ajiban beat Simon